arguments are
extraordinary things
painful things sometimes
but fantastic ways of clarifying thought
that could be
arguing with your partner arguing with a
friend arguing a law court arguing in
parliament
but for me at least all these types of
arguments
show where the truth is going wrong
helps you to think more clearly and in
my case helps me to change my mind
a successful argument basically
starts with
a really good grasp of the subject you
need to choose your subject well
secondly structure
it needs a very clear beginning middle
and end
thirdly
the content of it the words the phrases
the metaphors the jokes the things that
give it life
and finally
emotion
and the way in which that's carried out
not just in the words but in your voice
and in the way that you move your body
when i'm making a speech or i'm about to
go into a formal public argument
i firstly work out very clearly what the
structure is what are the
two points or five points that i'm
trying to land
then i think very carefully about
memorizing the first line and the last
line so that i can finish on a strong
point
and then i walk and practice speak and
practice speak and practice and
sometimes it just flows sometimes it's
magical and sometimes you find that
something you thought was going to be
magical has become all kind of tortured
and contorted and too complicated and
it's not really working
arguments
go wrong in many many different ways one
of the main ways in which we go wrong is
that we just lose control of our words
and we lose control of our emotions
emotion is very very dangerous in
argument
it can really put people's back up
and really upset them
and we we feel at a sort of animal level
somebody's emotion coming at us and it
can make us sort of shut down and no
longer listen to the words but at the
same time
emotion done properly is really the only
way
to win an argument because nobody's just
going to listen to words so the master
in argument is somebody who can
perfectly calibrate when to hold back
and when to go for it
[Applause]
the best argument i've
probably ever won was in the first
leadership debate when i was running
against the other candidates to be
leader of the conservative party to be
prime minister britain
and i suddenly found about halfway
through the debate that i had the right
type of comparison to use and i suddenly
remembered that i'd been trying to put
three bin bags into the rubbish bin at
home and my wife said you're never going
to get these three huge bags of rubbish
in and i was tempted like michael
and i'd like dom to say believe in the
bin believe in britain right it's it's
nonsense they are not going to get a
different deal out of europe we all know
that they they know it themselves i
produced it and i won the audience round
and i won the debate
the worst argument i had in my life was
the second big tv debate i did when i
was running to be leader of the
conservative party and this was my
big chance to prove that i could be
prime minister and i thought i had the
most killer argument and i was just
going to say to boris johnson
how are you going to get brexit done by
the 31st of october
and i kept asking the question and
nobody would answer and i got more and
more wound up with myself and my whole
body language kind of cramped up my
voice became
very contorted i took off my tie very
bizarrely in the middle of this debate
and i felt yep within about
two paragraphs i'd managed to lose
uh my entire vision for britain tonight
you were a bit lackluster weren't you
you're right i didn't find that format
really worked for me and i'm going to
have to learn how i i flourish in a
strange format of alternative reality
[Music]
one of the great changes in the history
of argument is of course the arrival of
television because suddenly it's
possible for people to view politicians
in particular in action
and the great moment where this really
came into prominence was the tv debate
between
kennedy and nixon about who was going to
be president
and famously nixon won on radio
in fact his arguments were much more
serious much more thoughtful but kennedy
just glowed on television and that's
what really won him the presidency
i love arguing on twitter there's
something very very satisfying about the
discipline of that word limit you get to
put out your argument
and then somebody comes back and then
you come back at them and i love the
clarity of that it's a beautiful way of
arguing which wasn't available to us
until twitter was around
one of the things that's
very difficult about argument is that in
the modern world we often see it as a
very very bad thing arguing sometimes
it's seen as a very male thing a very
aggressive thing something that makes
people unhappy
it's almost a form of bullying but if
you don't argue
it is very very difficult to get to the
truth if you just let everything slide
if nothing gets challenged if you don't
try to really pin down what somebody's
saying
you get a very lazy form of thought and
the lazy form of thought
in the end is a version of lying
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video